Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and since the
Terminus people on Walking Dead have been
outed as Cannibals I wanted to do a bonus
video explaining the Hunters in the Comics
since they’re very similar.
It’s also possible they could be doing some
scenes from the Tainted Meat storyline in
Episode 2.
So I’ll explain those when I post my Review
tonight.
New Round of the Giveaway starts when I post
that too.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment.
The show also cast two new characters that
I’ll explain at the end of this video.
So careful for spoilers through the premiere,
but as mentioned.
The Hunters are a group of cannibals in the
comics.
They’re not exactly like the Termites but
they appear in issues 61 through 66, so if
you want to read along in the comics you should
check out Volume 11 Fear the Hunters, it combines
all those.
Their leader is named Chris and they’re
a small band that preys on people instead
of hunting animals because they think people
are easier to catch.
As a group they might be a little worse than
the Termites, they ate their children.
The Termites we know ate each other, if you
remember the kill floor in episode 1.
Scott Gimple confirmed that the body being
chopped up here was Gareth’s brother.
Still somehow eating your own children sounds
worse than eating your adult brother.
So the Termites aren’t quite as bad as the
Hunters.
In the comics, Rick and the Survivors run
into the Hunters on their way to Washington
DC, they don’t say exactly where they are
on the map.
But it’s somewhere between Atlanta and DC
in the middle of nowhere, like the woods we
see around Father Gabriel’s church here.
It’s also around this time that they run
into Father Gabriel in the comics, so just
more evidence that they’ll do some Hunter-Related
moment on the show.
Chris and his Hunters start chasing down the
survivors and it turns into a hunt or be hunted
arc.
Andrew J West, the actor who plays Gareth
is very similar to Chris.
The jackets they’re wearing even look alike.
After the finale last year he was upgraded
to cast Regular.
They only do things like that if they intend
to feature a character in most of the episodes
during a season.
So if you’ve read the comics, I think they
will change some things from the Hunters storyline.
It’s possible that Rick and the Survivors
could capture Gareth and he would become their
prisoner.
Michonne has her katana here, so it’s possible
she takes it off the body of a dead termite.
Father Gabriel’s church is one of the big
locations from the comics, and from the way
it looks here.
It’s possible the Survivors could use it
as bait for the Termites.
Hunt or Be Hunted.
I think they’ve even been using that language
in the promos.
Scott Gimple already said that there would
be villains this season to rival the Governor.
He didn’t say there would be another governor
character, he just said their would be people
or a person that’s just as evil.
I don’t think he was talking about Gareth,
since he’s kind of a cannibal hipster.
And Hipsters are mostly harmless.
Feel free to make all the evil hipster jokes
you want.
I do think they will adapt some of the Hunter
moments but I think Gareth is a much bigger
character than Chris.
If you have read the comics, just please use
spoiler tags if you’re going to talk about
what happens at the end of their storyline.
The whole arc in the comics mirrors a lot
of the changes I think we’re going to see
in Rick’s character.
Since he’s the conscience of the group,
naturally everyone else starts to adapt with
him.
Hunt or Be Hunted.
So they all slowly learn to be Hunters.
Not cannibal hunters like the Hunters group.
But you get the idea.
They just stop being such easy prey for people
like the Termites.
The whole arc of The Hunters in the comics
is fairly self contained, but it’s a crucible
that everyone walks out of looking way more
badass.
If you remember Rick at the end of season
4 when he bit into Joe’s Neck and they killed
all the Claimers.
It’s just the natural progression of that.
This is going to be a big season for Andrew
Lincoln.
It makes me wonder how long he’ll stay with
the show.
He’s not getting paid crazy money compared
to say the Big Bang Theory actors, but I think
he could stay till the main show goes off
the air.
I don’t expect the actors from the main
show to appear on the companion show.
That’s just what they’re calling the spin
off that’s going to start next year.
Which reminds me, two new characters were
just cast.
On the main show that is.
For Season 5.
Alexandra Breckenridge is going to play someone
named Samantha.
That’s not someone from the comics, but
just like Gareth, she could be like someone
from the comics with a different name.
Her character description reads: attractive,
strong, smart, charming and articulate woman
with a vulnerable side.
She's a mother with a bohemian spirit, and
a talented artist
She’s not going to appear for a while.
They
just cast her in the last week and they’ve
already shot the first half of the season.
So we probably won’t see her till next year.
You might have seen her on American Horror
Story, she usually plays some sort of temptress
with really gruesome consequences.
But that doesn’t necessarily mean she’s
going to be having sex with Rick or anything.
If they do make it to Washington DC by next
year, it’s possible she could be one of
the new characters in the Alexandria Safe
Zone.
They are casting another character named Donna
right now, but they haven’t picked an actress
yet.
Supposedly Kate Burton from Scandal is their
top pick.
The funny part about this is that in the comics,
Donna was the mother of Ben and Billy.
On the show they gave their storyline to Lizzie
and Mika.
The other new character we haven’t seen
yet is Noah, he’s being played by Tyler
James Williams from everybody hates chris.
He’s not someone from the comics either.
It sounds like he’ll be in at least a few
episodes, so I don’t think we’ll meet
him till after the Survivors leave Father
Gabriel’s Church.
So I will be posting my episode 2 review tonight
after the episode airs.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
If you do have requests for bonus videos just
let me know in the comments.
I love doing comic and tv show videos so either
is fine.
I also might do some Walking Dead streaming
on my video game channel so I’ll add a link
for that in the description.
Right now click here for my Episode 2 Review.
I’ll add the annotation tonight when I post
it and click here for this week’s Q&A.
Thanks for watching, let’s all high five
and I’ll see you guys tonight!